[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره
كشفيات تحقيق لبرنامج ما خفي اعظم والذي
يبثه على الجزيره عن تفاصيل ومشاهد حصريه
لعمليات نفذها مقاتل كتيبه جنين وعرين
الاسود بالضفه الغربيه ضد قوات الاحتلال
والمستوطنين التحقيق وعرضه لقطات تنشر
لاول مره عكسته التطور الذي شهدته كتيبه
جنين التابعه للسرايا القدس الذراع
العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي وايضا مجموعه
تعارين الاسود في نابلس
وتوعد قائده سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري
للجهاد الاسلامي اكرم العجوري بمزيد من
المقاتلين وكشف في مقابله الحصيه مع
برنامج ما خفي اعظم عن اختراق السرايا
لجهاز الشباك الاسرائيلي عبر مجندين
متزوجين
بجانبه تحدث قائد مجموعه عرين الاسود في
نابلس عن جاهزيه بجنون المجهولين وكشف ابو
فلسطين في مقابله حصريه لبرنامج ما خفيه
اعظم عن عروض بحوافذ ماليه وامتيازات من
التلقاها عناصر العرين من السلطه
الفلسطينيه لتسليم السلاحهم مقابل الحفاظ
على حياتهم
نجح زعيم الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي كيفما كافي في الحصول على
الاصوات اللازمه لانتخابه رئيسا للمجلس
وحصل على 216 صوتا في الجوله الخامسه عشر
من التصويت وقد هنا الرئيس جمال كارفي على
انتخابه رئيسا لمجلس النواب وقال انه
مستعدون العمل مع الجمهوريين عندما يمكنه
ذلك
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قواتها اضطرت
لتدمير مواقع تابعه للجيش الاوكراني بعد
قصفها مواقع الروسيه عقب دخول الهدنه حي
ذا التنفيذ
ظهر امس الجمعه فقد المتحدث باسم الوزاره
الاوكراني وصل قصف تجمعات السكانيه هو
مواقع الجيش الروسي رغم التزام القوات
الروسيه بالهدنه
في المقابل قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه على الكسندر ان القوات الروسيه
شنت امس الجمعه 13 ضربه يستهدفت بشكل
اساسي البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه اضاف
اسطنبول ان تهديده بتنفيذ هجمات الروسيه
على عموم اوكرانيا مازال قائما
في هذه الاثناء اعلانات وزاره الدفاع
البيلاروسيا وصول قطار يحمل جنودا ومعدات
الرئيسيه الى بيلاروسيا اضافه الوزاره ان
القوه الروسيه الروسيه المشتركه على تم
الاستعداد للدفاع عن حدود ما سمته دوله
الاتحاد
نقلت وكاله واسعه برست عن رئيسه تايوان
ستاي انجون قولي ان تحركات الجيش الصيني
في مضيق التايوان لا تقدم العلاقات بين
الجانبين ولا ترسموا في الاستقرار والسلام
في المنطقه وكانت رئيسه تايوان تتحدث
اثناء زيارته قاعده عسكريه في مقاطعه
الشايب وسط الجزيره امس الجمعه
[موسيقى]